the Avengers have one job to protect
people the actors that play The Avengers
have an even harder job though
protecting the secrets of the next big
Marvel blockbuster and some of them are
better at it than others so it's a good
thing the fate of the world doesn't
depend on their silence because
otherwise earth would be doomed
thanks to these Marvel actors who
revealed big spoilers about Avengers for
Sebastian Stan spills secrets it may
seem like every character in the MCU
appeared in Avengers infinity war but
according to the Winter Soldier himself
Sebastian Stan the cast of the sequel
will be even more stacked stand till the
independent there was one scene I think
we had where everybody was there it took
them three months in planning this scene
to have everyone there you look around
and you just saw everyone from samuel
l.jackson to michael douglas to michelle
pfeiffer everybody was there considering
Stan Jackson Douglas and Pfeifer were
all turned to dust by Thanos and
Avengers infinity war and the ant-man
and the wasp post-credit scene this
might be the biggest spoiler of them all
as it implies they'll all be brought
back to life hmm
Zoe Saldana slips up the official title
of Avengers 4 has been kept tightly
under wraps with Marvel Studios head
Kevin Feige suggesting that it's
actually a spoiler for infinity war
however some fans thought they had
gotten the scoop when Zoe Saldana told a
reporter I think that the Guardians just
shot their part when it comes to
infinity war like the first part and we
all have to go back for gauntlet later
this year guardians of the galaxy
director James Gunn later said that
Saldana misspoke and that the title
isn't Infinity Gauntlet at all
whatever the case Feige told IGN he
regrets making such a big deal about it
to begin with it's gotten entirely out
of hand and now we'll have no chance to
living up to any expectations of what
its gonna be and it's sort of backfired
if I'm honest with you because the
notion was to not talk about it so the
focus was to be on infinity war
Drax deflates death almost all of the
guardians of the galaxy were lost at the
end of Avengers infinity war but while
they stayed at former guardians director
James Gunn had said he'd plan to
conclude the team's
storyline and guardians of the galaxy
vol 3 he has since been fired
but it still seems reasonable to assume
that a lot of them will make their way
back from the dead
in the fourth film star Dave Bautista
seemingly confirmed that his Drax the
destroyer will be one of those people
saying in an interview with Collider
after Avengers infinity war I got a lot
of text saying I can't believe you're
dead your character is dead they were
really like heartbroken and I was like
I'm gonna be in Avengers 4 I'm gonna be
in Guardians 3 I don't know how they're
bringing me back yeah but somehow I'm
going to make it because as far as I
know I am going to be in Guardians 3 so
I have to be back this was all so
seemingly confirmed by Chris Pratt who
said in an Instagram post that he can't
wait to start shooting guardians vol 3
with co-star pom claimed on tip
considering both of their characters
star-lord and mantis also bit the dust
alongside Drax and Avengers infinity war
it certainly seems some sort of mass
resurrection is in store for the
guardians of the galaxy Bannos snaps
back Josh Brolin's Thanos did away with
most of the MCU heroes in infinity war
but the post-credits scene for the film
hinted that there was still hope for the
universe in the form of brie Larson's
Captain Marvel who will be introduced in
her own 1990 set standalone film before
joining the rest of the gang for
Avengers 4 although we've known for a
while that Captain Marvel will appear
Brolin appeared to drop at least a bit
of a spoiler when he said that he shared
a scene with Larson hinting that Thanos
will have a head-to-head confrontation
with her Carol Danvers Brolin also
revealed that Black Widow Warmachine
Thor Captain America and Iron Man were
present which is notable since those
characters were all among the few
survivors at the end of infinity war
Stark jr. Gwyneth Paltrow's appearance
in infinity war hinted at a happy future
for Tony Stark and Pepper Potts with
Tony suggesting that the pair could soon
start a family Paltrow though revealed
even more in an interview with the
official Avengers infinity war magazine
suggesting that the dream will actually
come to fruition in Avengers 4 saying
pepper and Tony have had a real long
journey together she obviously starts as
his dutiful assistants and then the
relationship evolves and now this decade
later they're married and they have a
child their relationship has evolved in
all of the ways that great romances
can't keep a good Macky down Falcon
didn't make it through the end of
infinity war but anthony mackie may have
inadvertently revealed that he'll return
from the great beyond in December 2017
the star tweeted a photo of himself from
the set of Avengers 4 saying sometimes
you have to sit back and marvel at where
you are and sometimes you have to just
celebrate being alive again Heimdall's
and Hyman downes although a lot of
characters seem to be making their way
back for Avengers for at least one
apparently won't be addressed Elba whose
character Heimdall was killed at the
start of Avengers 4 revealed on his
Twitter account that he would not be
coming back
writing spoiler alert gonna miss my guy
hey at least he put a spoiler tag on it
[Music]